apparently mlb spoke directly to stacey
abrams before they decided to move the
all-star game oh well if stacey abrams
is super pissed maybe we ought to just
cut off all business with the state of
georgia then you are explicitly
political actors and you will be treated
as such
we have a large issue in the united
states that is worthy of talking about
and that is that there's a huge swath of
america that believes they're engaged in
the quote-unquote resistance when they
are in fact the dominant
upper hand in american politics right
now these folks are not the resistance
they are the most powerful voices in our
society
and posing themselves as the resistance
allows them to get away with quashing
descent
i'm old enough to remember when the
democratic party suggested that
corporations should have no voice in
politics at all corporations were not
people
corporations were bad bad bad bad bad
this is why we needed campaign finance
reform because if you
owned a corporation and you gave money
from your llc
to some sort of of campaign this meant
that you were engaged in an attempt to
strip american democracy
of all of its plenitude it was an
attempt to get rid of the diversity of
american democracy using institutional
power now however the left has realized
that they ought to do with corporations
what they've done with nearly every
other institution in american society
and simply grasp the means of
distribution
and they're now going to leftise all of
the means of distribution
of institutional power in our society
the greatest indicator of this of course
is that apparently on sunday there was a
meeting of more than 100
chief executives and corporate leaders
they gathered online sunday according to
the washington post to discuss taking
new action
to combat the controversial state voting
bills being considered across the
country
including one recently signed into law
in georgia so you now have
major corporations that have decided to
just do the work of the democratic party
and the reason they're doing the work of
the democratic party is because they
believe that the democratic party
is in an unbreakable ascendancy right
now they believe
that the country is moving ever more
leftward and that there is no worry that
there will be backlash from the right
and so they are just going to do what
the democratic party wants them to do
and in return presumably the democratic
party will leave them alone a little bit
or grant them additional regulatory
power or give them tax breaks
or ensure in some other regulatory
fashion that their opponents are stifled
that's what's really going on here
because if you believe that all these
major corporations
gave two dams about georgia's voting law
which again does not really does not
restrict the right to vote
it does not voter id is not a
restriction on the right to vote
maintaining more ballot boxes than there
were in 2016 is not a restriction on the
right to vote
broadening voting hours in many counties
is not a restriction on the right to
vote
but these corporations know that they
have to just become the
another wing of the democratic party the
privatized wing of the democratic party
or the democrats are going to come after
them until they are caving
on behalf of the democrats this is
extremely dangerous stuff there are
tens of millions of americans who work
for these companies
i saw a chart over the weekend it showed
the political donations from employees
of america's biggest companies
nearly all a majority of those com
majority of employees those companies
gave to democrats
so what we are watching is the complete
hijacking of corporate america on behalf
of the radical left
and then you will watch a cram down
happen internally inside these companies
and an attitude taken with regard to the
customer base that requires that you
exceed
to their politics this deeply dangerous
stuff these corporations
have decided that they are going to just
shift into the democratic party playbook
and they're doing something different
than corporations have done in the past
corporations have always given money to
politicians
there's been a thing for a very very
long time in american politics and that
is not rare
nobody would be surprised to see the
heads of google give money to democrats
nobody be particularly surprised to see
the heads of walmart give money to
republicans right none of this was
particularly shocking
what is shocking is that corporate
america is now seeking to punish the
voters directly
that is a different thing okay so
corporations deciding
that they want to give to this
politician or not give to that
politician
those are corporate political decisions
they've been going on for a long time
right they have lobbyists those
lobbyists have been working in
washington
literally for for at this point
centuries in america
but there's a different thing going on
when you have corporations that are
openly targeting the voting population
and attempting to bully them into voting
the way they want that is a different
thing
entirely it's amazing the same left that
will suggest that corporations are
bullying their own employees
for not pushing in favor of unionization
that's not bullying that is just a free
market exchange
those same people will be perfectly
happy with corporations
removing their business from places
simply based on the politics of those
places and how people voted in those
places
and they are ecstatic that mlb removed
the all-star game
from atlanta georgia because georgia
georgian voters decided that they were
going to
vote in favor of republicans in the
state house
punishing the population is a very very
different thing than punishing
particular politicians nobody's saying
you have to give to republicans you want
to be a corporation and give to
democrats
so be it don't expect a lot of help from
republicans on the other end
right why would you but if you are if
you are a corporation and you are
targeting the voting base itself
that is a completely different thing
frankly this is a standard that we've
had
with our own advertisers here on shows
like this one now they're advertisers
who have decided they no longer want to
advertise with us
that's their prerogative but when you
target the people who listen to the show
when you say the people who listen to
the show
are bad or their views are bad and
they're not doing business because you
don't like the views of the people who
listen to the show
well then you're on the other side a
business decision is not the same as a
political decision and these
corporations are jumping full skill into
making political decisions
by attempting to blackmail states that
is what they are doing right now these
are major corporations remember these
are the people who are in
institutional power these are not
outsiders attempting to stop
the march of fascism these are political
insiders extraordinarily connected
extraordinarily wealthy
this is not the masses who are
attempting to rise up against power
this is the powerful the voters of
georgia are significantly less powerful
than the heads of google and mlb
no question about it according to
jeffrey sonnenfeld a yale management
professor who organized the call
executives from major airlines retailers
and manufacturers plus at least one nfl
owner
talked about potential ways to show they
oppose the legislation including by
halting donations to politicians who
support the bills and even delaying
investments in states that pass the
restrictive measures now again
your prerogative you don't want to give
money to republicans again don't expect
that those republicans are then going to
rush to your defense
when it comes to you proclaiming your
allegiance to free market principles
because you don't give an in-bound free
market principles obviously you're
backing the party that stands against
them
but by the same token very different
thing if you've decided you are
literally going to boycott those states
if you're going to boycott those states
now you have engaged in political
warfare upon your own consumer base you
have decided that people who don't think
like you
ought not consume your product fine you
believe that we will take you up on that
we'll 100 take you up on that and we'll
fight back as consumers we'll start our
own businesses
these are dangerous dangerous things and
by the way it seems to me perfectly
justified that in america
in which anti-discrimination law rules
the roost in which
anti-discrimination law which has been
in the ascendancy in the united states
since the 1960s
for originally some good reasons and now
some very bad reasons
anti-discrimination law
which is rooted in the idea that freedom
of association
is must be curbed in the name of ability
to patronize
if you believe that then it seems to me
well within the realm of possibility
that states are simply going to start
adding
political orientation as a basis for
non-refusal of service
in states across the country that if
you're gonna do business in georgia
you don't get to decide who you do
business with based on politics
otherwise you can just leave it seems
like that is the way that a lot of these
states are going to go i know that
discussion
is being had at the highest levels in
some of the red states you're seeing
right now
because governors are not going to allow
their their states to essentially become
the preserve of corporations that wish
to
bludgeon their constituencies into
silence
according to the washington post while
no final steps are agreed upon the
meeting represents an aggressive dialing
up
of corporate america's stand against
controversial voting measures nationwide
you think they give a damn about this
seriously these controversial voting
measures by the way again are
less restrictive than many voting
measures in states like delaware for
example
these corporations didn't care five
seconds ago but corporations
are notoriously slow to react and quick
to overreact
so they're slow to react to trends then
when they sense the trend
they react in radical hammer fashion
nothing is done with a scalpel
everything is done with a chainsaw
and so instead of these corporations
being going to the republican
legislature in georgia and saying here
are the provisions that we don't like
this one and this one
instead of doing that they wait until
the law is passed and then they see that
stacey abrams is super pissed and then
they're like oh well
if stacey abrams is super pissed maybe
we ought to just cut off all business
with the state of georgia
this is not going to work out well for
you guys it's not going to work out well
for you guys because guess what
if you guys decide not to do business in
the state of georgia there are plenty of
other people who are more than happy to
do business in the state of georgia
the consumers don't go away the
businesses do
all of this came just days after senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell warned
that firms should stay out of politics
echoing of you shared by many
conservative
politicians and setting up the potential
for additional conflicts between
republican leaders and the heads of some
of america's largest firms
now again the media are playing this is
the republicans are the reactionary ones
nope the corporations are the
reactionary ones they're reacting to the
predations of the radical
left and then republicans are reacting
to the fact that all of these
corporations have decided to target
their voters
by the way it's now coming out that
stacey abrams seems to be a liar
stacey abrams said that she had no
impact on mlb moving the game apparently
mlb spoke directly to stacey abrams
before they decided to move the all-star
game
leaders from dozens of companies delta
american united starbucks target
linkedin levi strauss boston consulting
group
along with the owner of the atlanta
falcons were included in the zoom call
we'll have more on this
in just one second because this is a
truly dangerous trend in american life
it's going to lead to the breakup of the
country
okay so according to the washington post
the discussion
which was scheduled to last one hour but
went on for 10 minutes longer was led at
times by ken chennault the former chief
executive of american express
and kenneth frazier the chief executive
of merck who told the executives it was
important to keep fighting what they
viewed as discriminatory laws on voting
both chanel and frazier are of course
black and they coordinated a letter
signed last month by 72 black business
executives that made a similar point
now all of this could stop if
corporations just said no that's the
amazing thing about this all
corporations have to do
is say listen we are not in the business
of signing
into debates over voter id and it's just
not in our purview
what's in our purview is how for example
the the government regulates
corporate earnings what is within our
purview this is
part of the other problem right so
there's two problems one corporations
have moved beyond
simply targeting politicians based on
their stances and have decided to target
overt populations which is a big change
the other thing that has happened in
corporate america is that corporate
america has decided
and they are not going to restrict their
opinions to
areas in which the corporation operates
they are going to now
have opinions on everything it's going
to be like what does coca-cola
think about this this law in arkansas
that says that children
should not have medical experimentation
done on them for purposes of transgender
verification
well i mean their silence is deafening
right well we have now reached the point
in corporate america
we have reached the taylor swift's
silences deafening point
in corporate america for those who are
not aware of this meme for years taylor
swift was
fairly apolitical and then everybody
online kept saying
whenever there was a controversial thing
happening in american politics taylor
swift silence is deafening and those of
us on the right were like um she makes
music why do you care about what taylor
swift has to say
and then taylor swift got hit so hard so
much
from the left that she decided to go
fully woke and she started producing
songs like 10 years late about gay
rights she turned into
pop star never stopped never stopping
right in that in that movie which is
very funny there's a there's a
andy sandberg plays a character who's
this pop star
and he makes this pro gay rights song
but he's like 20 years late on it
and so everybody's like why is he even
making this that was taylor swift she
makes this gay rights song
like 10 years after gay marriage becomes
a thing in the united states
everybody's like why is she well it's
pretty obvious why she was doing it she
was bullied into it by the left
corporations are now the taylor swift of
our politics corporations have decided
that they are going to their silence is
deafening they must speak out on
everything the left demands of them okay
guys well if that's the way you want it
that's the way you're going to have it
if you're going to engage in the ultra
crepitarianism speaking outside your
purview in which you are not commenting
any more about corporate tax rates or
the restrictions on sugar imports from
cuba
button stick as coca-cola but instead
you are now going to comment
on bathroom bills in north carolina then
you are explicitly political actors and
you will be treated as such
and the consuming public will do so and
republican legislators will do so and
that is not reactionary on the on the
part of republicans that is not them
starting the fight that is them
simply saying if you guys have chosen to
engage in this field you will be treated
as somebody engaging in this field you
will be treated as an adjunct to the
democratic party which is what you are
the call's goal according to the
washington post
was to unify companies that had been
issuing their own statements and signing
on to drafted statements from different
organizations after the action in
georgia
sonnenfeld said the leaders called in
from around the country
some chimed in from augusta georgia
where they were attending the masters
yeah i noticed that rob manfred did not
in fact
the head of mlb did not in fact give up
his uh his membership to augusta
national
and i've noticed that coca-cola has not
moved its corporate headquarters i've
noticed that cnn by the way has not
moved its corporate headquarters which
is located in atlanta which means
presumably they endorse the georgia
voting law
that's the way this works right
sonnenfeld this professor from yale he
says there is a defiance of the threats
that businesses should stay out of
politics
they were obviously rejecting that even
with their presence on the call but they
were there out of concern about voting
restrictions not being in the public
interest yeah sure
or they were there because they know
they're getting blackmailed by the left
and they are deeply afraid that there
are investment
pension funds union pension funds run by
the seiu
that are going to pull money from their
stock price well again this game can
work both ways
this can work both ways if by the way
these folks think that that joining with
corporate america is going to gain you
massive popularity
let me recommend that you take a look at
the republican party which joined with
corporate america in nearly every
iteration over the past 30 years and
proceeded to lose
massive amounts of power in the united
states it turns out that you know what
americans typically don't like big
corporations cramming down their views
and it's even worse when those big
corporations have decided to move out of
the realm of tax rates corporate tax
rates and have decided to move into the
realm of
what do we think your children should be
learning in school i do not give two
craps with kenneth chanel things my kids
should be learning in public school
i don't want to know what american
express thinks about this i have no
interest in them
and if they try to tell me what to do
i'm just not going to patronize their
business
i will take out a different credit card
and if all of the credit cards decide to
do this there will be regulations that
prohibit them from doing this in red
states
you can see how these corporations are
going to wield their executive power
in order to damage the american people i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content